it's just so clear this is something we
have to do both to live better as as
human beings and and with each other but
it's also like the you know there's a
shot clock on on on climate right now
and I want to make sure that you know I
and and we our whole company can scale
our impacts
light ship is the first American
all-electric RV Manufacturing Company
there were a few catalysts to starting
the company I was at Tesla for about
five years I was a battery engineer
there and I worked on the model 3
battery and I had this Pet Project which
was to Electrify all of the food trucks
in the Bay Area I wanted to work on food
trucks because I'm an engineer I would I
would go every lunch you know lunch time
to one of these food trucks but there's
actually kind of a rotating Circuit of
them and I was always so annoyed by
these gas generators that are always
running in the background when you want
to uh you know place a panini order for
instance and you're screaming over them
so this pet project that I had to
Electrify all of the uh the food trucks
in the Bay Area anytime that I would
tell somebody else about the project
rving always came up
right at the start of covid I like
everyone else was was cooped up in in my
apartment and it was kind of the final
straw I was like I've got to do
something here and so I rented an RV
that for about three months that that
whole first summer of covid and it was a
30-foot Winnebago Motorhome and I
basically Road tripped it around the
whole the whole American West for about
6 000 miles I met a bunch of other rvers
of course on the road rving I came to
realize was it was sort of the place to
work on it was it is the next Frontier
of electrification for for vehicles that
was the point where I was like okay yes
I'm gonna do this I want to devote a lot
of my life to to try to Electrify this
this industry the RV industry what is
unique about what we're doing is that
first off it is a new category of
vehicle and not one that much attention
has been paid to when it comes to to
electrification yet we were doing it
from the ground up which is very unique
as well so instead of putting together
all the pieces we've designed it from
the beginning so it is purpose built for
electric vacation it's very clean it's
quiet it's all these things that you
want ultimately what that means is you
can camp a lot longer you can you know
you can drive longer range and it
doesn't cost an arm and a leg
first time founder I'm sort of new to
the game and so I'm learning a lot about
managing people it's you know it's a
growing team and so that's really kind
of the almost like the nature of every
week or at least every couple months
that the feeling is is different and and
there are you know
new challenges for me to learn to
confront there's a little bit of
imposter syndrome but I guess the
reality is I just uh even though I know
that I don't have
all of the skills or experience yet to
do this I know what we have to do and so
yeah I think I think it's
you know it's just trying to do right by
people and right by the team and and
make something that lasts
[Music]
our fundraising Journey so far has been
we raised a small precede round off of
Angel Investors right around the time
that things really picked up as my
co-founder Toby joins we raised a seed
round from obvious Ventures which is a
great kind of consumer and climate
focused Venture firm in based in San
Francisco between the the pre-seed and
the seed we raised about four million
dollars and we raised another 23 million
with a series a so 27 million raised
total in venture capital
[Music]
we realize that we have to be very
Scrappy as a complex Hardware
manufacturing company to make sure that
we're using the capital in the right
place and also going as fast as as we
need to one of the things that I've
learned here is that time is kind of the
enemy in in building a startup every
moment that you're not making progress
is imperils the company ultimately so
we're just trying to be really judicious
about you know how we use the funds to
get to the point where we have this
awesome show vehicle we have you know
revealed the product to the world we've
launched the brand alongside it and
opened up a you know a pre-order Bank to
show just you know just how excited the
world is to own this thing
I would like to be known as one of the
people who was at the Forefront of
electrifying RVs and vehicles in general
I feel like a duty of service to push
all vehicles to be electric and yeah I I
hope I'm known as not just the man from
Target but also that electric guy
[Music]